it's time for scene and unseen where we
explore the cultural stories of the day
and for that we turn to Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo author of the
fourth come in the unexpected light of
Thomas Alva Edison all right Ray Chris
Rock a year later finally responded to
the Will Smith Oscar slap I'm already
kind of sick of this story but you've
seen something I know but Lord there's
something a lot of others have missed
this was calculated Revenge by comedy
and it was part of Rock's Netflix live
special but before the big finale Rock
took on wokeness Meghan Markle even
abortion I'm on your side I
believe you should have the right to
kill as many babies
but let's not get it twisted it is
killing a baby
Laura this was blunt force truth and you
know there was that bait and switch
where you know at the beginning he made
it seem like he was on the side of
everybody here and then he kind of does
that bait and switch uh it was good
comedy but the entire hour really built
up to the final eight minutes where he
blamed the infamous slap on Will Smith's
wife Jada Pinkett Smith
she said
this man should quit his job because her
husband didn't get nominated for
concussion and then this gives me a
concussion a lot of people go
Chris how come you didn't do nothing
back cause I got parents that's why
because I was raised you know what my
parents taught me don't fight in front
of white people
I like that line that was hysterical I
thought I thought well he's I think he's
a very talented it's you know not all my
type of Comedy but I mean I thought it
was pretty effective
well look it's it's he's hilarious I
mean his observational comedy is spot on
I have to say though the thing people
came for the Will Smith bit it was it
was really not a special as much as a
special it was very abbreviated and it's
too close to him he's still hurting from
this thing and your takeaway is Chris
Rock doesn't really find this all that
funny it's still too personal but
another comedian Marlon Wayans had an
HBO special called God loves me the
entire show was about this slap entity
claims Chris Rock will end Jada Smith
wronged him years ago and he prayed to
God for Relief then last year at the
Oscars he got it
that was a hard slap that was that slap
had three slaps in one slap
only God could
we saw her roll our eyes up in her head
but that ain't what she did she put a
spell on him
and the Ghost of Tupac Shakur possessed
just Will Smith's body let me see
[Applause]
this hour he did an entire hour milk the
entire hour from this Oscar slap it was
far more effective because it wasn't so
personal he had the distance to laugh at
it the Marlin weigh-in special is a riot
no I
aren't you and
Nikki Haley one of the Republican
candidates is calling for mental
competency tests for those politicians
over the age of 75. what do you think
about that ridiculous
would your husband ever take one of
those
I mean we haven't even discussed we
would never even discuss something like
that
why wouldn't they discuss it Laura when
the president's having trouble walking
upstairs as he did yesterday I mean he
keeps stumbling every time he gets onto
Air Force One and when his major
addresses sound this way make it be a
cognitive test is not out of order
I had these terrible headaches was
diagnosed with having a
so anyway
they had to take the top of my head off
a couple times and see if I had a brain
we're moving in a direction to
fundamentally change the way in which my
validity to save the planet they're
going to spend a total of I believe 12
million bucks or 13 I think a billion
billion and they're going to build two
Fabs they call them factories
Laura only 37 percent of Democrats in
that AP poll recently want Biden to run
again this is why they can only fake
this for so long and you know you watch
this and you think Jada Pinkett Smith
may not be the only one in the spell
book you know getting her husband to do
things he doesn't want to do we'll see
what happens here but uh I'm not sure if
he's ready for prime time or another
Raymond Raymond that answer to the
I mean to the this point about that they
took my head off to see if I had a brain
that was a little too close to the truth
I mean that was that was very disturbing
I thought that he was trying to make
life Joe Biden long enough he does speak
the truth as unpleasant as it is at
moments no it was very sad but now I'm
gonna watch the weigh-in special it's
still on HBO I'm watching it all right
Raymond thank you for giving me
something to watch me all right I'm
watching hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else